un reconocimiento a las voces que se
rehúsan a ser silenciadas en el centro
de memoria paz y reconciliación de
bogotá se llevó a cabo la edición número
10 del premio nacional de los derechos
humanos una distinción para destacar las
acciones de todos aquellos que día a día
luchan por la defensa de los derechos
humanos en colombia una tarea difícil en
un país que se sigue construyendo con la
idea de alcanzar la paz los premiados
fueron divididos en cuatro categorías
defensor del año' defensor en los
últimos 30 años proceso colectivo del
año y ong
formando el territorio y los aires el
despojo territorial y también en el
cauca no esto también se hace con
complicidad detestaba detectados aquí
los que tenemos nosotros de un estado
que viola permanentemente los derechos
humanos pero aún estaba que aunque tiene
vigilancias recomendaciones
recomendaciones no está cuidando y
protegiendo la vida
[Música]
según cifras del instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo y la paz en lo que va
del año 140 líderes sociales y
defensores de derechos humanos han sido
asesinados a esto se suma el asesinato o
desaparición de 41 firmantes del acuerdo
de paz y ex combatientes de las farc
este este reconocimiento
contribuye de manera significativa a
minimizar esos riesgos y amenazas
hostigamientos y persecuciones de los
que somos víctimas líderes y liderezas
en el país por defender los derechos
humanos en colombia en 2016 el acuerdo
de paz firmado entre el gobierno
colombiano y la y guerrilla farc llegó
con aires de esperanza y reconciliación
cinco años más tarde la oportunidad para
alcanzar esa paz se estaba agotando en
una colombia con niveles de violencia
que el estado ha sido incapaz de
controlar